quoi
françois mitterrand sur antenne 2 deux
thèmes majeurs les bouleversements à
l'est et les limites de l'immigration en
france
après la pologne la tchécoslovaquie se
dote d'un gouvernement à majorité non
communiste l'écrivain contestataires
vaclav havel pourrait succéder à guus
avoue sac à la présidence de la
république
l'immigration en france étant
officiellement interdite les demandeurs
de droit d'asile politique sont en
augmentation difficile de démêler le
vrai du four enquête dans ce journal
si le mot document un sens il correspond
à celui que vous allez voir ce soir le
destin la vie d'un polonais victime
vient d'un terrible accident qui l'a
privé de ses deux bras et pourtant qui
lui est comment madame monsieur bonsoir
premiers titres de l'actualité de ce
dimanche soir bien évidemment la longue
interview que vient d'accorder le
président de la république monsieur
françois mitterrand sur notre cher jean
louis ii scène nous en fait
immédiatement un résumé et un premier
commandes
daniel pendant les six mois de
présidence à la tête de la communauté
européenne
françois mitterrand n'a pas ménagé sa
peine et multiplier ses rencontres avec
les onze partenaires de la france
résultat pendant ces six derniers mois
le chef de l'état n'avait guère eu le
loisir d'évoquer devant les français les
problèmes qui les inquiète dans leur vie
de tous les jours
certes ce soir monsieur mitterrand
encore parler de l'europe au lendemain
du sommet de strasbourg de la
réunification des deux allemagnes
monsieur collet décidément européen on
n'a pas le droit d'en douter
il a évoqué à nouveau les soubresauts
qui agitent l'europe de l'est pourquoi
avoir peur à chaque fois que la liberté
gagne du terrain
mais pour la première fois depuis les
événements récents le chef de l'état a
parlé de l'immigration du foulard
islamique de la construction de mosquées
dans les villes et de la percée du front
national sur l'immigration
ce n'est pas un problème français mais
européen pour l'immigration clandestine
c'est le renvoie dans les conditions du
droit et monsieur mitterrand a bien
insisté sur son refus de revenir sur
l'abrogation de la loi pasqua et ses
noms dans l'immédiat au référendum
proposé par jacques chirac sur le droit
de vote pour les immigrés pour les
immigrés qu'on a accepté à une époque
pour des raisons d'autres c'est
l'intégration qui sera la règle pour
ceux qui sont de nationalité française
qui on est et qui ont été naturalisés
le problème ne doit pas se poser sur le
front national le président de la
république
voulu minimiser son essor se refusant à
croire que la xénophobie gagner du
terrain sauf dans quelques villes zagato
qu'on montre toujours en exemple dans le
sondage ipsos paru ce matin dans le
journal du dimanche les français avaient
classés dans l'ordre décroissant leurs
préoccupations justement en prévision
des missions de ce soir en tête et de
loin le chômage et l'emploi
ensuite l'intégration des immigrés puis
à construction européenne enfin bien
après la situation dans les pays de
l'est
force est de constater que ce soir on a
parlé de tout mais pas dans l'ordre les
bouleversements intervenus et qui se
poursuivent donc en europe de l'est ont
tenu vous l'avez entendu une large part
dans cette interview présidentielle
chaque jour apporte il est vrai son
nouveau changement
demain matin les quatre puissances
alliées victorieuse en 1945 est garante
du statut de berlin qu'elle occupe
encore militairement doivent justement
se réunir pour décider notamment un
certain nombre de mesures visant à
faciliter l'accès à la vie et puis
surtout aujourd'hui la tchécoslovaquie
après la pologne a été le deuxième pays
de l'est à se doter d'un gouvernement à
minorité communiste même si le premier
ministre est membre du pc et si les
postes clés sont toujours détenues par
des ministres commune le président de la
république tchécoslovaque monsieur
gustavo sac celui qui avait dirigé la
normalisation du pays après 1968
démissionne et tout porte à croire que
l'écrivain contestataires vaclav havel
va lui succéder
prague christophe martet on restera à
quelques centaines de mètres de la place
venceslas ils se sont rassemblés devant
le siège du forum cynique c'est par la
télévision qu'ils ont appris la
formation du nouveau gouvernement et les
pragoise d'entonner l'hymne national
aujourd'hui même les communistes
semblent satisfaits de la nouvelle
équipe gouvernementale
moi et ma femme nous sommes d'accord
avec cette nouvelle conception de la
démocratie
avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et
pourtant je suis communiste
j'ai l'impression qu'on est sur le bon
chemin que maintenant les choses iront
mieux qu'est ce qu'ils attendent
maintenant de ce gouvernement
la liberté c'est après deux jours de
tables rondes entre pouvoir et
opposition que le premier ministre a
présenté le nouveau gouvernement un
gouvernement ou le parti communiste
n'est plus majoritaire
quant au programme civique il a réussi à
obtenir pour sept personnalités sans
parti des postes importants notamment
les affaires étrangères les finances et
un poste de vice-premier ministre
prochaine étape politique en
tchécoslovaquie la nomination par
l'assemblée nationale du nouveau
président après l annonce de la
démission de gust à boussac ce soir
tranquillement les prag ont quitté la
place wenceslas théâtre d'un nouveau
week-end plein de rebondissements
preuve de cette décontraction la grève
générale prévue pour demain est supprimé
mais à 12 heures tous les klaxons toutes
les sirènes toutes les cloches du pays
sonneront en signe de joie
tout est historique ou presque en ce
moment en tchécoslovaquie et à l'est
comme cette poignée de main qui vient
d'intervenir à l'instant entre le
président démissionnaire gusta à boussac
le fossoyeur du printemps de prague et
le nouveau ministre des affaires
étrangères monsieur diam's tirs
ancien porte parole de la charte 77 vous
l'avez vu qui a passé trois années en
prison et qui a été constamment
surveillé par la police
la bulgarie elle aussi se met en route
progressivement vers une refonte de son
gouvernement cent mille personnes ont
manifesté aujourd'hui à sofia pour
réclamer l'abolition du rôle dirigeant
du parti communiste en bulgarie et
l'organisation parallèlement à cela des
élections libres même revendication
d'ailleurs à moscou un défilé était
organisé pour demander l'abrogation de
l'article 6 de la constitution
soviétique établissant le rôle dirigeant
dominante des partis communistes en urss
ce que tentent d'éviter d'ailleurs pour
l'instant le numéro un soviétique
monsieur gorbatchev pas de changement
précipité il l'a répété hier devant les
instances suprêmes du pays
moscou au téléphone nicolas jacobs
mais pourtant 4 à 5000 mètres devant le
stade olympique certains brandissant des
banderoles ou de tambours batteur
d'autres critiques quant à son action
ayant plusieurs caciques on pouvait lire
à bas les imposteurs avec l'article 10
ça résume 3 l'imposteur et dans les
membres du parti communiste plus tard
louis kings 3 400 personnes étaient
portées par les unit dans steam bilan au
moins un blessé une dizaine
d'interpellations à chaque fois pour les
manifestants il s'agissait d'obtenir
l'abrogation du rôle dirigeant du maquis
comines un premier pas vers le
multipartisme
le débat agite en ce moment toute la
sphère politique soviétique
même les progrès quant à l'urgence une
telle réforme
ivan basso a ramené hier lors du plénum
qui n'était pas opposé et pour plus tard
mardi ce sont les débuter une saison
vraiment de cette question avec pour
certains la volonté d'enchaîner si toute
l'europe de l'est bouge la chine elle
reste de marbre immobile c'est en partie
pour cette raison que d'anciens
souverains et chefs religieux du tibet
occupé puis annexé par la chine depuis
30 ans s'est vu décerner cette année le
prix nobel de la paix le dalaï lama qui
a reçu officiellement cette distinction
cet après midi à oslo valérie fort des
tibétains venus accueillir la 14e
réincarnation du dalaï lama lors du
vivant tenzin gyatso de son nom de
mortel et le chef spirituel du tibet
entre dans le temple de la paix ce prix
nobel
une distinction que pékin déjà qualifié
de nuisibles à l'unité de la chine le
dalaï lama âgé aujourd'hui de 54 ans
avait fui en 1959 son pays pour l'inde
après l'échec d'un soulèvement populaire
contre l'occupant chinois depuis son
combat n'a pas cessé pour la paix et il
s'agissait bien de cela aujourd'hui ans
lou car après avoir reçu une médaille à
l'effigié d'alfred nobel
et un chèque de 3 millions de couronnes
suédoises le dalaï lama a menacé pékin
de reconsidérer sa position
si la chine persiste à refuser le plan
de paix qu'il a proposées en 1987 avec
cette distinction aujourd'hui plus que
jamais pékin ne parviendra à brider ni
le nationalisme de la population ni son
attachement le dalaï lama
à l'autre bout du monde c'est toujours
l'incertitude dans l'archipel des
comores au milieu de l'océan indien le
mercenaire français bob dénard ya pris
le pouvoir depuis une semaine après
s'être débarrassé du chef d'état qu'il
avait lui-même d'ailleurs contribué à
mettre en place deux là bas la france a
dépêché à mayotte et à la réunion des
renforts matériels hommes et navire vous
les voyez mais pour l'instant pas
question d'intervention armée tout au
plus une aide éventuelle à l'évacuation
de ressortissants français bloqués sur
l'île où la situation est parti assez
tendu une manifestation de jeunes ayant
été assez sévèrement réprimés dans les
territoires occupés par israël le
deuxième anniversaire de la révolte des
pierres a été marqué par son lot
quotidien d'accrochages qui ont fait
deux morts palestiniens et sept blessés
cette guérilla incessante n'est pas sans
conséquence sur l'attitude et le moral
des soldats israéliens qui sont avant
tout vous le savez des citoyens et qui
s'interroge sur la finalité de leur
action jerusalem charles en guerre
un contrôle méticuleux tout est vérifié
tout et couzier ce barrage routier
marque les jours de grève
l'entrée de la zone militaire de djénine
dans le nord de la cisjordanie près de
deux cent mille palestiniens y vivent
dans 59 village est si petite ville le
secteur est commandée par le colonel
amos
il a 34 ans tu aujourd'hui dit-il le
soulèvement palestinien est en perte de
vitesse nous pouvons nous déplacer sur
toutes les routes de la région
il ya beaucoup moins de manifestations
violentes et puis nous nous sommes
adaptés
nos véhicules sont maintenant bien
protégé en deux ans l'armée israélienne
c'est bardé de plexiglas et de grillages
ce qui a considérablement réduit
l'efficacité des pierres lancées par les
jeunes palestiniens essentiel de
l'activité des militants du soulèvement
se déroule donc la nuit il leur est plus
facile de disparaître dans ce village
la veille plusieurs hommes masqués ont
été capturés le colonel amos est venu
préparer une nouvelle opération
j'essaye constamment d'être en avance
sur l'adversaire d'eau penser comme lui
et souvent je le devant ce qui est votre
ennemi comment le définissez vous il
m'est difficile de parler d' ennemi pour
moi militaire l'ennemi ce le soldat d'en
face que l'on combat avec une arme avec
un temps que lors d'une guerre ici il y
a le civil qui pensent lutter pour son
indépendance
certains veulent s'attaquer physiquement
mais hommes ceux là sont mes ennemis
il est 11 heures du soir amos vient de
marquer un point dans le jeu du chat et
de la souris qui l'oppose au soulèvement
ces soldats ont découvert des banderoles
du matériel qui devait servir un défilé
dans un village
le couvre feu a été imposé sur la
localité
les soldats vont ils patrouillaient
toute la nuit ils ont l'ordre de tirer
sur tout homme masqué qui n'obéiraient
pas aux sommations en france maintenant
accident cardiaque pour le numéro un du
parti communiste français monsieur
georges marchais déjà victime d'un
infarctus il y a quelques années de cela
il a été hospitalisé cet après midi à
l'hôpital lariboisière à paris mais le
professeur slama le cardiologue qui le
soignent affirme qu'il s'agit là d'un
incident bénin suite un dérèglement du
rythme cardiaque de monsieur marchais
qui a été immédiatement donc régulariser
monsieur marché restera deux ou trois
jours en observation
là à tourner engagée par le mouvement
sos racisme à la suite de la sphère du
foulard islamique s'est achevée hier
soir dans le var par une grande réunion
8000 personnes et un discours du
président des sceaux et ce racisme
harlem désir
répétant inlassablement comme il le fait
depuis plusieurs années que les hommes
politiques doivent résoudre les
problèmes de l'intégration de manière
pratique sinon on donne aux extrêmes dit
il le droit d'exploiter et d'aborder ce
problème
alors justement ce problème de
l'immigration on en a beaucoup parlé
tout à l'heure avec le président la
république se pose sous diverses formes
ainsi aujourd'hui en france
l'immigration économique étant
officiellement stoppées et bien les
demandes d'asile politique augmente
cinquante mille par an et sur ce chiffre
il faut démêler le vrai du faux
exemple choisi est le département du
haut et du bas rhin un certain nombre de
turcs souvent d'origine kurde tente de
passer la frontière française
espérant ensuite régulariser leur
situation ce qui les met dans une
situation dramatique et les autorités
régionales dans une situation plutôt
délicate reporter de nice bauer vers
leur teneur depuis le début de l'année
380 turcs ont demandé asile à l'alsace
ils sont kurdes ont fuit la turquie où
ils ont tout laissé la misère les drames
politiques pour arriver dans cette
france dont on leur a tant vanté
l'accueil ainsi ce couple a vendu ces
quelques lopins de terre sont maigres au
cheptel pour environ 40000 francs
de quoi acheter deux passeports et la
filière clandestine qui les amenés ici à
strasbourg et istambul grave et le
voyage a duré trois mois
on était trente turc on est parti
d'istanbul depuis izmir et la tunisie où
on est resté deux mois par la filière on
a trouvé la possibilité de partir pour
alger puis ou sdat et casablanca au
maroc à casablanca pendant cinq jours on
a vécu dans la rue avec notre bébé qui
avait un mois on a traversé l'espagne et
l'autriche et on a pu passer la
frontière à strasbourg on ne peut pas
repartir on a eu trop de problèmes
alors on va refaire une demande pour que
la france nous accepte contiendra depuis
trois mois ce couple vit séparée
hébergés dans deux foyers différents
leur petite fille de 9 mois
placé dans un foyer de la dass
leurs instants de bonheur et d'intimité
ils les doivent à la générosité d'amis
turc à dj et ahmet n'ont semble-t-il pas
choisi le meilleur moment pour venir en
france
je crois qu'on ne peut pas être pour
l'exclusion totale
on ne peut pas être non plus pour l'abus
de l'accueil et de l'asile en france
c'est entre ces deux positions extrêmes
que doit se situer une politique
présent depuis deux ans plus de 80 % des
demandes d'asile ont été rejetées ça
veut dire que de ce qu'on appelle des
goûters alors ils seront donc s'acheter
par l'ofpra
ils seront responsables de l'office de
protection des réfugiés et apatrides ils
ont la possibilité de faire un recours
devant ce rejet sur recouvrent leur
permettra de rester en france mais à
l'issue de ce recours similaire à
nouveau négatif ils seront dans
l'éducation quitter le territoire
français
le problème se posera ce si ces gens là
entre temps ont pris attache ont pris
quelques racines on entonne emploi ont
des réseaux familiale autour d'eux ou
simplement un réseau d'amitiés et ça va
être difficile de les faire partir de là
les arracher à ce milieu naturel
c'est là dans ce camp maladroitement
baptisé centre de rétention que ces
exclus séjour d'une semaine avant de
regagner leur pays parfois l'expulsion a
lieu dans les 24 heures à l'issue d'une
garde à vue
côté police
grande vigilance à toutes les frontières
les aéroports les trains les frontières
françaises sont dorénavant bien étanche
mais pour les clandestins le meilleur
moyen est encore de passer à pied en
déjouant l'attention des patrouilles
mobiles à la frontière suisse 6 à 7
turcs sont arrêtées toutes les semaines
les gens qui sont en situation
irrégulière doivent savoir ce qu'ils
risquent et savoir ce qui peut les
attendre mais en même temps si nous leur
disons qu'ils ne peuvent pas rester sur
le sol français il faut qu'il puisse
aussi se faire entendre et se faire
défendre trois pieds et ça c'est une
condition absolue ce que demandent les
migrants c'est très simple c'est ce que
demandent d'ailleurs aussi ceux qui ne
sont pas mes grands c'est qu'il n'y ait
pas des immeubles qui soit entièrement
réservé à une deux ou trois communautés
qui n'est pas d'immeuble dépotoir qu'ils
puissent être associés ou devenir de
leur quartier qui puisse avoir des
enfants qui vont à l'école normalement
qu'ils puissent disposer d'un soutien
pour l'alphabétisation pas toutes sortes
de mesures que nous pouvons prendre et
que nous devons prend en attendant ces
mesures la misère s'est installée se
mobilisent alors toutes les associations
les asile de nuit
l'art offre le gîte et le couvert
pendant le temps où ils espèrent une
régularisation de leur dossier qui sera
acceptée ou refusée et ça peut durer
plus de deux ans brièvement maintenant
plusieurs faits divers deux évadés de la
prison de lannemezan ont été appréhendés
la nuit dernière dans un bar de la ville
de pau cela fait donc quatre détenus
repris au total et 5 toujours en cavale
une enquête administrative a été ouverte
le ministère de la justice reconnaissant
que la direction de la prison de
lannemezan était au courant d'une
tentative d'évasion en cours de
préparation puis ce matin quatre
prisonniers considérés comme dangereux
se sont évadés de la prison de mende en
lozère ils ont pris en otage un gardien
pour franchir les portes de
l'établissement pénitentiaire armé d'un
pistolet dont on ne sait pas encore s'il
était réelle ou factice
on en sait un peu plus ce soir sur la
découverte du corps du petit tarik
disparu depuis une semaine de son
domicile à bourganeuf dans la creuse son
corps a été retrouvé sans trace
apparente du moins de violence et tout
fait sans doute par son assassin voici
maintenant un document exceptionnel ou
plutôt incroyable c'est ce que nous
avons pensé d'ailleurs lorsque nous
l'avons reçu et pourtant l'homme dont
vous allez connaître maintenant le
destin est bien réelle c'est un polonais
victime d'un terrible accident mais qui
n'a jamais voulu renoncer à la vie
quelle leçon quelle obstination aviv
commentaires de stéphane magnier durée
carlos qui a le goût de la provocation
de son infirmité
il ne cache rien il arbore même en signe
de défi presque avec fierté
je suis né il ya 41 ans je vis au sun de
viège en pologne
quand j'étais petit je voulais devenir
peintre ou champions sportifs mais à
l'âge de 12 ans j'ai perdu mes deux bras
brûlés par un transformateur à haute
tension ma vie elle et les futures j'ai
voulu me suicider et puis je me suis
ressaisi et même sans bras j'ai voulu
devenir un grand athlète
le combat pour la vie dans l'oeuf ce qui
va être à la dimension de son caractère
grandiose et rageur il apprend d'abord à
sauter pour fortifier ses jambes parce
qu'il veut devenir skieurs pas d'argent
pour payer les remonte-pentes qu'à cela
ne tienne il remonte à pied pas les
moyens de s'offrir un moniteur
qu'importe il apprend en regardant les
autres
et bientôt ils sautent
mais cela ne suffit pas il veut devenir
plongeur acrobates
il apprend d'abord au tremplin olympique
de plus en plus haut jusqu'à faire des
exhibitions du sommet des grands pontes
pologne
de tous ces exploits il y aurait sur
leur ce qui ramène 64 médailles des jeux
olympiques pour handicapés et fautre
championnat 30 d'or 24 d'argent 11 de
bronze ou s'entendre dire au bout du
compte qu'il n'ya pas de travail pour
les manchots comme lui alors le ski se
révolte contre cette société qui
l'exclût il apprend à être un criminel
avec autant de soin qui l'a mis à
devenir un sportif son coup favori à
semer les gens à coup de tête par
surprise pour les dévaliser avec ses
dents mais ils cambriolent aussi avec
des passe partout
trop facile à identifier il lui prit
repris arrêtés et condamnés
j'avais 20 ans on m'a condamné à 20 ans
j'en ai passé 11 derrière ces murs c'est
là que iorek orlowski va transformer sa
vie une troisième fois
cette fois ci il a le temps d'apprendre
mais pas des espaces alors il va puiser
dans son deuxième rêve d'enfant devenir
un artiste un dessinateur un peintre
bien sûr les thèmes et les visages qui
l'expriment sont imprégnés de sa
souffrance de ces tortures mais juste
retour des choses
cela lui donne sa place parmi les autres
aujourd'hui
ses oeuvres sont vendus jusqu'aux états
unis parfois avant même d'être exécuté
sa dernière victoire
peut-être la plus belle aussi la plus
discrète urech orlowski est marié et
père d'un petit garçon de 11 ans
fantastique leçon également fantastique
leçon de solidarité de générosité donné
par les français à l'occasion du
téléthon 89 sur antenne 2 ce week-end
255 millions de francs de promesses de
dons contre 185 l'année dernière record
battu au terme de trente deux heures
d'émission non-stop
chaque viol on est là on attend a tant
souffert reste que je pouvais sauter
très haut plus haut que les autres à la
preuve que
que je marchais trente deux heures
d'émotion de joie et surtout d'espoir
dans les regards de ses enfants
le coup d'envoi de l'opération a été
donné vendredi à 19 heures des milliers
de bénévoles 500 techniciens tous les
moyens de direct d'antenne 2 2 et fr3 et
de radio france dans des dizaines de
villes de province
les spectacles des animations 26 centre
de promesses et partout des records
battus soit 1500 lignes de téléphone
sont saturées mais aussi des exploits
sportifs auxquels participent les jeunes
malades bonjour maman tu me regardes ce
fait un gros bout
et puis tous les sens avec la fatigue
henri sannier et une vingtaine d'autres
entrants dans le speedo 102 à la maison
de la radio
après avoir passé 42 heures sur leur
vélo entre bordeaux et paris et enfin la
satisfaction d'avoir dépassé tous les
espoirs par le parrain de ce téléthon 89
alain de l'euro devrait conclure par ce
chiffre époustouflant président 252
millions quatre cent trente mille francs
on aurait pu faire mieux mais je crois
qu'on fera mieux l'année prochaine puis
je voudrais dire ceci aussi que nous
avons tous essayé de faire de notre
mieux ce soir pour vous aider
toute la journée les dons ont continué
ce soir plus de 255 millions un pari
gagné un formidable élan de solidarité
dans l'actualité de ce dimanche à
signaler encore une certaine tension
entre les médecins généralistes et le
gouvernement le syndicat des médecins
généralistes réclament une convention
spécifique sans lien avec celle des
spécialistes
faute de réponses distillées bien cette
semaine il réfute seront toutes les
propositions gouvernementales avec les
conséquences que l'on peut imaginer sur
le remboursement des assurés sociaux de
leur côté il faut signaler et les
médecins spécialistes sont déjà en
conflit avec les pouvoirs publics
sport maintenant football
essentiellement les clubs de 1re
division jouer cet après midi je retiens
deux matches bordeaux battus par sochaux
et montpellier qui reprend un peu espoir
après avoir triomphé du paris
saint-germain olivier rey coup de froid
pour le leader borgo battu cet après
midi par sochaux qui trouve ici
l'ouverture à la 25e minute par son
défenseur croci en seconde période
sochaux assure sa victoire la suite de
ce corner grâce à une reprise de la tête
de carrasco qui trompe belle autre fait
marquant de cette journée la victoire de
montpellier sur le paris saint-germain
grâce à ce premier but de vincent guérin
un tir terrible qui ne laisse aucune
chance à joël valls
en seconde mi-temps montpellier aggrave
la marque grâce à un deuxième but signé
eric cantona
voir rassurante pour montpellier qui en
avait d'ailleurs bien besoin
les autres résultats de cette 22e
journée metz a battu marseille 3 à 2 une
seule victoire à l'extérieur monaco à
saint-etienne un seul match nul toulouse
et auxerre un parcours précieux succès
de nice sur lyon grâce un but de rich or
le racing s'est imposé devant nantes 2-1
succès important de caen sur braise de
toulon sur mulhouse et de lille / cad au
classement statu quo en fait
bordeaux possède toujours trois points
d'avancé sur marseille sochaux est
troisième à dix points monaco 4e à 9
points
dans le bas du tableau l'écart se
resserre entre l'île 10e et nice dernier
onze équipes se tiennent en quatre
points seulement à une journée de la
crème au beaucoup de neige mais
suffisamment de même pour le ski slalom
géant de val d'isère ce matin victoire
manqué de très peu pour le français
franck pika que vous voyez en ce moment
longtemps en tête
il croyait à sa victoire mais finalement
il a été dépassé par un concurrent
inconnu partie en 37e position
le suédois nicklausse henning que vous
voyait descendre ici et triomphait dans
quelques instants
les vainqueurs également cet après-midi
dans le tiercé qui se courre est à
auteuil pour gagner vous allez voir les
chiffres s'inscrire sur votre écran il
fallait jouer le 17 le 5 et le 15 pour
gagner un peu plus de 7 16 me france ont
beau tiercé pour ce qui concerne le
quarté + et bien ajouter à ces trois
chiffres
le neuf et vous gagnez là une très belle
somme plus de cent soixante seize mille
francs voilà si vous n'avez pas gagné
vous pourrez toujours vous consoler dans
quelques instants avec les prévisions
météo du début de semaine fait et
réalisé par josée blanc lapierre le
dernier journal c'est aux environs de
minuit maintenant avec le décalage suite
à l'interview du président d'un public
c'est philippe gassot qui vous
présentera c'est tout le dernières
informations demain soir ici même vous
retrouverez avec quant à moi je vous
retrouve d'abord mardi soir pour un star
à la barre consacré justement un
problème dont on a beaucoup parlé ce
week-end sur antenne 2 le business les
affaires de la charité avec un certain
nombre d'invités une émission
passionnant j'en suis sûr
et puis on se retrouve samedi prochain
pour un autre week end ensemble j'en
suis ravi à l'avant je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée une excellente semaine
et je vous dis à samedi bonsoir